Robbi him always he lat a home a new
home or a booyah
yr adran ara matter who why a harpoon
bahu in merepeka can maha bua and what
led me and cause me to come to a point
the brink of one in the leaf tower okay
guys welcome to this video
assalamualaikum i'm going to be sharing
with you guys a personal matter that is
close to me and the personal shoppers
that I went through with the Quran and
the dowel yes I actually came to a point
where I actually wanted to leave Dawa
why did I want to leave that WA now
there was a variety of reasons and and I
was quite serious I've actually like
said if I can't do this I'm leaving the
dollar mm now there was a variety of
things there was things that you know
before this might be intentional
intentional novel and go out these
people I'm just telling you guys the
facts that happen
you know being mocked for not being able
to read the Quran now bear in mind yes I
might have a dog hair dark eyebrows and
look like of course Kohl in my eyes but
that doesn't mean I was born a Muslim so
I'll revert to Islam and a lot of time
sometimes people expect a lot from you
and they just forget sometimes even my
teacher say what I will forget the river
a lot of things would add up you know
when you're being mocked and when you
genuinely know yourself you're trying
your best you're generally trying your
best and it's hard so the actual matter
here at hand is that me being able to
read the Quran this is something that
I've struggled with for a lot I can say
for the first two years when I first
came to Islam I didn't take priority in
it yes for god knows what reasons it was
just a mistake I just didn't really take
priority in learning how to read the
Quran but as things progress I wanted to
I genuinely wanted to and I tried my
best and it's a bit like when you're
studying you know you try to be in a
student of knowledge it's hard it
doesn't work just you just learn
everything at once it doesn't work like
that it
a gradual progress and is also to show
how determined you are and a lot is
going to test you I was gonna test you
of everything yes even if it means
learning the Quran learning how to read
the Quran and so I started joining etc
and I was looking and obviously at that
time there was some issues I had with
certain brothers etc you know may Allah
bless them I don't have any ill feeling
towards them but the thing is it's that
you know I would be marked etc you know
I don't know how to read the Quran
you're doing dower there are cetera I
understand what they were coming from
but at the end day with me I was
passionate seeing people disregarding my
religion lying about my religion that
bothered me and in my head I couldn't I
wouldn't say to myself ok let me stop
tower until I know how to read the Quran
I said no look I can I know the basics
of tawheed let me carry on Dow and that
was something on the way that can do but
obviously people took that different I
know you shouldn't give dower you should
stop tower that was Haram for you you
should not do it etc now obviously you
put it puts you down to a certain point
even though I can say I'm fixing hello
people say you know but the thing is
sometimes it does get you I carried on
but what thing one thing that really was
trying to get to me was because I was
looking for teachers I was looking for
someone that can actually on a constant
basis teach me and may have a blessing
my teachers it's not their fault but you
know they'll be busy you know hundred
like you know start at nine Rashid
Moose's dad I know it with him he would
try to help me learn the alphabet cetera
but he would be busy with his own things
and obviously this without his phone it
would just get to me like uh you know we
started two weeks and then third
rheostat has to trouble
that's not he's forward you know it's
just I'm looking for ways out so handle
I would start that journey I would start
trying to go to other classes and then I
didn't study my hamdullah helped me a
lot a lot but obviously because of my
lifestyle I work I have to work because
I have to work I don't have the time I'm
not lucky as those who do not work they
they make a living of whatever they may
be selling excess whatever they're doing
and they have that time to study I
didn't know how to work continuously
I've had to work one way or another
people you know me ve but before you bar
I would do work in different ways you
can I'm trying to say and that's the
reason why these obstacles come in the
way so I was thinking how am I going to
find somewhere where I can study
but fits into my routine yeah so it was
hard I couldn't and then obviously
outside that butter brilliant place I
would recommend every single one of you
guys to go and study there you know if
you don't have a hectic lifestyle like
me go and study there brilliant handling
me and I blessed him they helped me a
lot in variety of ways I went there
every Saturday but I lived in like near
North East London and I had to travel
all the way to near hate it was a long
journey and then what happened is when I
start working for uber and I had some
debts for other personal reasons and
what happened is it was becoming hard
because Saturday the days
uber drivers know that you know that's
what he made the most money Friday
Saturday and Thursday you know so it
became hard so that got in the way in
that home because I had a routine and I
was happy but now I have what am I gonna
do pay my debts or do the Quran I didn't
know you know I said I have to you know
there's people that owe money so I had
to not go Saturday's that affecting me
because I was like oh man finally I
thought you know when you have this
hobby it's a bit like you read me a bit
like my marriage documentary when I was
looking to get married and I would have
meetings over meetings and it was now
happening and I wasn't happening it just
gets to you those of you guys when you
start washing documentary you yourself
would know it just gets annoying like
you know is this the barn yeah finally
nope it's not working out again back to
square one it really gets you and I set
myself a deadline I said by this
deadline I would make Dwolla please give
me a way out give me a way that I can
learn your column you're on your book
you know and I'll make a lawsuit oh and
sometimes we make - what we want
immediate change is not you want a lot -
we think in our head that Allah sends a
light and then all of a sudden I start
memorizing Quran on top of my head it
doesn't work like that Allah asks do all
in different ways in mysterious ways you
know and that's why I said if you fear
me I'll give you away are from places
you can never imagine I've lived that
through my life so obviously I was
feeling frustrated etc I'm doing new but
I said to myself you know what if by a
certain amount of time if I don't
somehow managed to find somehow way to
learn the Quran I'm leaving the doubt
I'm just leaving because within myself I
don't feel right
how could I not know the Kalam of Allah
Japan hotel and go out there and preach
now this could be argued someone can say
okay look you should learn you're
willing to learn it's not like
one INT alone you understand basic now
answering etc you know toe heat you know
you know the basic fundamentals of
Tawhid etc it wasn't a reason you know
my teachers would you know tell me look
it's not it's not reason you want to etc
so obviously I'll try it well through a
lot of Memphis and one point I just came
and I think this is like it's like a lot
sooner
it's not when you just have that you
just talk to lose that hope and you're
like okay I'm just gonna be the dour or
anything whatever it may be that our
largest and just things just change very
drastically sappin the law so I was at
this point where I said you know I'm
leavin that with us self I can't I can't
carry on I just I just feel I just do
not feel Rights just a personal opinion
and hamdulillah all praises belong to
allah subhanaw taala
raha Sufyan may Allah bless him he was
doing studying he was studying with a
Koran teacher online on zoom and he just
said to me bro you know like if you want
to recommend it to you etc and I said ok
bro I can try it you know and then a
fourth NIT I just [ __ ] let me just
try it let's see what happens you know
not fear you know nothing up to me says
ok let's try our house all singing house
house that the same man I want it more
live in person you see I'm trying to say
so if I left to go it's option so handle
lot I started on zoom now the thing is
brother and sisters if you want to do
something you would not give up and if
you want to do Allah will give you a way
out just you just know why you want to
do two things why and how you
acknowledge and understand and figure
out why you want to do it as long as you
acknowledge why you want to do and it's
accordant of quite an alumna and then
your intentions are right leave the how
you're gonna do it to Allah and that's
exactly what happened in my journey
hamdulillah my teacher I'm sowwy
Muhammad hamzawy who's in Egypt and I
started Quran lessons with him every
week and hamdulillah you guys supported
Salaam and that would obviously handle
both you my personal development which
is the Quran so 100 on now
I do like 24 hours a month 6 hours a
week with my core and teacher and it
works so well for me because it fits in
my busy schedule so I'll have a time
time so if I'm doing ooh boy or
something comes out back into Stacia
I can I can WEEE today at 10 is 10 a.m.
in the morning but can we do at 9 p.m.
sure he fits so perfectly into my
lifestyle
that when I'm doing uber
this gonna be dead between certain times
I could just tell Shaq like sure can we
do it between this time yep perfect it
worked so well so perfect that I never
fought in a million years that while I'm
doing a bar I'm going to have a teacher
I thought how would that be possible how
long I'm gonna find a feature that
teacher that fits in my schedule but you
see when you want to do something and
your intentions are right allah subhanho
wa taala will provide and from there
onwards handle Lois Lee I didn't leave
the tower and now hamdulillah today I
was at propositions house I'm visited
him while I was reciting Quran do my
class he decided to record me so hundred
and now I'm more fluent in reading the
Quran something that I never imagined
you know something that I never imagined
and my teacher is someone that is so
jolly he like he makes me want to learn
like we have this relationship it's not
just not its the teacher-student
relationship we make jokes you know
sometimes if I flop somewhere who laugh
at me etc but one thing he said to me
said look look where he was before and I
hundra I thought to myself you know what
I'm never gonna get to I thought
whatever nah I don't think I'll never
Arabic was so hard I thought now how am
I gonna know and it was all these touch
weed rules and I was thinking there's no
way I can do this like how am I gonna
remember this but subhanAllah the way he
taught me at the end of it what he would
do is he would give me in droplets so he
would make me recite a verse in Quran
then I say okay this is hard this is fr
you know this is metal Azzam this is
this and these terminologies and then as
I'm going through another 15 robbed of I
I know these now and one point I
realized to myself I'm reading and he's
not correcting me as much I will go on
for like an hour listen you correct me
four times and then I realized he used
such a method that now hamdulillah
I finished the Quran not memorized even
though I do memorized or finish the
whole round from surah Naas to sort of
back are now reading it back up and my
intention is inshallah to carry on doing
that till the day I die
inshallah and I just wanted to share
this reminder with you guys because it
had a drastic effect on me and I was
nearly given up but hamdulillah making
dua and being firm allah subhanho wa
taala answered and whatever goals you
have as long as it's good as halal is
for the sake of allah subhanaw taala do
not give up carry on a lies test in you
yes Allah will test you in everything be
it reading the Quran so I share this
reminder
and sisters do not ever give up carry on
always and allah subhanaw taala will
give you a way out and if i did not go
through those struggles and those tests
and may have not appreciate what I have
today as much Baraka Rafiq Berkeley
Baraka laughs I come well I bless you
guys for listening
assalamualaikum warahmatullah better
care to leave your comments in the
section below if you have your own story
till next time
Salam alaikum make to us that inshallah
I will memorize the whole entire Court
and one day and for those who wanted me
to leave Dawa I'm sorry I'm here